this is a bottle of Dasani Coca Cola's
brand of bottled water it is basically
coke without the syrup like most
American bottled water it is tap water
that's been purified and then had tiny
amounts of minerals deliberately added
back into it except not quite this is a
British Dasani bottle from 2004 which is
the first and last time we could ever
buy Dasani water in the UK and the story
of white failed here is one of the
greatest marketing disaster stories in
history but it wasn't until I started
researching searching through newspapers
and TV shows from 2004 that I found that
the tale is a little more complicated
than I thought a little more complicated
than a lot of the Worldport and it
starts years earlier
throughout the 1980s bottled water was
something expensive we got ordered at
fancy restaurants and it was only by the
early 90s but it starts to become a
thing that everyday people might want to
buy on Christmas Day 1992 British sitcom
Only Fools and Horses made fun of that
trend by having its main character
lovable rogue Dell boy sell tap water
from South London as Peckham Spring
bottled water it's a slow an
old-fashioned comedy by today's
standards and the episode is really
weirdly paced your two thirds of the way
through before anyone actually starts
bottling water but because it was the
Christmas Day episode in 1992 back when
most British households only had four
channels of television that show was
watched by more than 20 million people
more than a third of the entire British
population and the final joke about
episodes that the water is contaminated
by some chemical barrels that tell boy
dumped in a local pond in the first act
it is to be fair a brilliant closing gag
and it's one that stuck in the British
cycle the BBC reran the episode another
five times in the years after it had
been on cable and satellite channels
many more times than that I would guess
that by 2004 when Dasani launched about
half the country maybe more could
understand Peckham spring as a reference
or at least remembered that time dell
boy tried to bottle tap water now under
UK law mineral water is a protected term
mineral water must come from a certified
underground spring it must not be
chemically treated in any way and it's
generally under heavy regulation and
back in 2004 the perception was that
bottled water meant mineral
water why else would you buy it it's
it's something you can't get at home
over in America though the home of
coca-cola and the perception of bottled
water the city was just that it was
water in a bottle you're paying for the
convenience and the taste and it didn't
really matter whether that came from the
ground or from a water purification
Factory
to be fair there are large parts of
America where the tap water does not
taste or smell good and their federal
standards aren't great particularly
compared to Europe and anyone who has
ever taken a vacation to Disney World
for example will know that the tap water
around Orlando can smell a little
sulphur but in the UK the perception was
different you were buying mineral water
because it was natural it has been
filtered through rocks for eons it was
classy and fancier and perhaps healthier
than what came out of your tap that's
rubbish of course we have some of the
safest tap water in the world and did
back then - but advertising is powerful
and the idea was that bottled water was
filtered and pure straight from the
earth it was somehow better coca-cola
were trying to introduce an
american-style filtered tap water to a
British mineral water market now they
were not lying about their water and
marketing didn't use the phrase tap
water they preferred purified water but
they weren't lying it says on the back
of the bottle their process precisely
delivers pure still water the public
might have assumed it was mineral water
but coca-cola never said that in fact
what they had done is spent a long time
with focus groups taste testing in
refining the mineral balance in the
flavour of the water making a version of
Dasani that was ideal for the British
palate Dasani launched with the first
stage of what was going to be a 7
million pound advertising campaign on
February 10th to 2004 and it went okay
for weeks the British publicly that
didn't notice or didn't care that it was
tap water the same way Americans don't
seem to care there were occasional rough
patches for the launch like shopkeepers
in Buxton a town famous for its mineral
water complaining about being forced by
their contracts with coca-cola to
replace bottles of the local water and
coolers with Dasani or the regulator's
launching an investigation into whether
coca-cola should be using the word pure
on the label but I'm whole went okay a
lot of articles written more recently
playing that coca-cola's first blunder
was coming in American Dasani slogan
can't live without spunk which has a
very different meaning in the UK but I
don't think that's true
the only actual evidence I could find
that slogan is a screenshot on one tech
news website that liked innuendo looks
like a web design and reuse some
American ad images in one part of a
flash-based web site that almost no one
saw no other article from the time that
I can find anyway mentions that slogan
at all the advertising was put together
by coca-cola UK division they're not
stupid
in fact the advertising teams probably
breathing a sigh of relief
All Things Considered the launch had
been successful and then it all went
wrong very very quickly exactly three
weeks after launch March the second most
of the major British newspapers
simultaneously put out big stories
announcing that Dasani was bottled tap
water
most of them mentioned that episode of
Only Fools and Horses and all of them
made a lot of noise implying that it was
a ripoff although perhaps they didn't
put it in quite so few words and back
when a lot of people actually read
physical newspapers front page news
saying that your product is a ripoff
does make a big difference to sales but
why was it suddenly news everywhere at
the same time after three silent weeks
the missing piece of the puzzle is one
journalist called Graeme his cot who
worked for the Press Association and as
he tells it as part of a brilliant
half-hour documentary made later that
year he happened to be flipping through
an issue of The Grocer an industry
magazine at work one day and you know
that's that's an event of the the
documentary asked him to recreate for
some reason now The Grocer is an ideal
source for journalists looking for the
next story about a product recall or
weird marketing strategy and that issue
of the magazine had a feature on bottled
water and there was just one line in one
article describing discerning as a
mineral enhanced treated tap water which
when written so clearly seemed odd so
Graham called coca-cola and they said
yes yet Dasani is treated tap water from
the main supply at their bottling plant
right there in Sidcup South London ten
miles from Peckham whether episode
fools and horses were set a few hours
after that phone call there was an
article on the Press Association news
wire about where Dasani came from
articles on the news wire don't usually
go straight to the public they go to
other journalists first who can use them
or adapt them and the editors and most
of the newspapers correctly decided that
yes this was something their readers
would be interested in six months
earlier on coca-cola was setting out
preparations for their Dasani launch the
grocer had run a small article about it
and there's a line in there that's
prophetic one senior buyer warned that
some consumers may be put off by the
waters lack of provenance and now coke
bottles tap water for three thousand
percent markup was on the front pages
but coca-cola under Sally sold it on
that didn't kill the brand they put more
marketing budget behind it they gave
away three bottles in supermarkets
another article in the grocer from back
then quotes Coca Cola's UK marketing
director there cannot be many people who
do not know about Dasani now I cannot
imagine how much we would have had to
spend to get that level of awareness
there is a theory that there's no such
thing as bad publicity through all the
final nail in the coffin was the
contamination they've had a bad batch of
calcium chloride delivered right here
it's one of the chemicals they used in
the purification process and tests
revealed that their water contained
above the legal limits of bromate a
cancer-causing chemical it wasn't
anywhere near enough in the water to do
harm but there was enough that it was
outside the legal limit so within 24
hours every unsold bottle was recalled
back here and the shelves were empty
just like Dell boy not only had
coca-cola sold tap water in a bottle but
they sold contaminated tap water in a
bottle Dasani never returned to shops
never launched in France or Germany like
milk planning and to this day if you
type Dasani into google UK you get
results about the disaster news reports
with 2004 on the first page coca-cola
launched other water grounds of course
but as far as I can tell they all look
to be spring waters or mineral waters
they're not hooking up a purifier to the
tap not over here there are other folks
some impurity at water of course but
that's usually the cheap option
she'll nothing matters it's all just
water and I reckon coca-cola could
absolutely have made this work maybe
they still could there is a world in
which one journalist didn't use the
words tap water or another journalist
didn't happen to look at one particular
article and where the launched went just
fine and Britain got used to the fact
that drinking bottled purified tap water
could be normal after all if it had been
a popular brand no one would want to
admit their purchases might be
questionable it's a lot easier to just
say yeah that's fine cause I know it's
tap water then go I'm gonna I've been
paying how much for what and worry that
you might have been ripped off I don't
think the Dasani disaster was inevitable
but it happened and all that's left 16
years later as a few bottles like this
[Music]
shame about the people honking wasn't it
yeah they might uh now I'll tell you
what we time that well because here
comes on Laurie